tragedy has once again struck the cast
of glee nia rivera is presumed
dead after a mishap at a lake outside of
los angeles
we have exclusive new reporting on what
was supposed to be
a pleasant afternoon out with her son
that went tragically wrong
we're going on the belief that she did
go in the water
we have both aerial search going on and
our dive team out here as well
and we have not been able to locate her
so
this may well be a case of drowning if i
die young bury me and satan
lay me down on a bed of roses
what do you think is the biggest
misconception that people have about you
um that i am fake
or you know or like trying to be
something that i'm not
you know i'm a mom now and i you know
what i love more than acting
is being josie's mom so i want to be
here for him
nya who starred in six seasons of glee i
think that the buzz that we've gotten is
really positive
grew up about 20 miles from lake piru
where search teams spent the day looking
for leads to her disappearance
an eyewitness tells e.t they saw naya
arrive with her son yesterday
at about 1pm and approximately three
hours after they left the dock
another boater out on the lake
discovered the
boat drifting and we've been actively
searching for
the mother the four-year-old told
authorities his mother went in the water
for a swim but never returned
her last instagram post was this image
with josie
from her marriage with actor ryan dorsey
i think you're holding back
nya was recently working on the step up
spin-off series which was picked up by
stars following two seasons on youtube
but she of course is best known for her
role as cheerleader
santana lopez when you went for the
audition for glee
you were ready to give up on acting
absolutely i mean i i reached a point
where i was like
i have to go to college and like try to
get a real job
and then my mom was the one that was
like just give it six months
[Music]
in march nya shared this pic and the
quote gravity keeps pulling me under
but the urge to breathe helps me stay
afloat and a week ago today
this heartbreaking post quote make the
most of today and every day you are
given
tomorrow is not promised
[Music]
it seems like that you really are in a
very good place
yeah you love being a mommy oh my gosh
yes what's the greatest thing about
being a mom everything i mean absolutely
everything you know
it's very early mornings but i am so
excited every morning and he always
greets me with a smile and it's just so
amazing to see
amid the news still coming in about naya
we are reminded of all the hardships
that have hit the glee cast when i got
the call about corey it was just like
your like world stops and you kind of
black out for a minute
but that was just a dream july 2013
corey monteith was found
dead in this hotel room in canada after
an
accidental heroin and alcohol overdose
girlfriend leah michelle along with the
rest of the cast was devastated
especially since corey had recently
completed a detox program
this is my humble abode in los angeles
california there's the indoor bar and
there's the outdoor bar
you know what's funny is i don't even
drink
[Music]
then in 2012 heather morris was the
victim of a nude photo leak
tomorrow marks the six-year anniversary
of the death of becca tobin's boyfriend
matt bendick who like corey monteith was
also found dead in his hotel room
a cause of death was never made public
you say you're tired and you just want
to close your eyes
2018 the body of naya rivera's ex mark
salling was pulled from a remote area
north of l.a
after he committed suicide the 35 year
old was awaiting sentencing in a child
pornography case which could have sent
him to prison
for four to seven years in 2016 nya told
us
she wasn't shocked by his arrest he
always was a very dark soul to me
and i always felt like you know just
from knowing him
so well i guess for the on and off three
years
i just always felt like there was
something that he was wrestling with
you're a legend well that's not the
general opinion these days but thank you
and most recently last month leah
michelle had to apologize
after major backlash involving her
co-star
i am not going to say that leah michelle
is racist some cast members spoke out
after leah supported the black lives
matter movement
only to have co-star samantha marie ware
fire back in a tweet quote
i believe you told everyone that if you
had the opportunity
you would bleep in my wig you did
document a couple times where you felt
like she was unprofessional
definitely on the set definitely nye has
always been open about her struggles
in november of 2017 she was arrested for
domestic battery after allegedly
attacking then-estranged husband ryan
in the presence of their son who was
just two at the time
the charge was dismissed and her divorce
was finalized seven months later
every path and every mistake and
up and down and in between in my entire
life i feel like it's already been you
know planned out for me
of course our thoughts and prayers go
out to nia's friends and family and
hopefully they can wrap their arms
around that little boy because he will
need it in the coming days
months and years